this show is brought to you by headspace
download the free headspace app now and
begin their take 10 program for 10 days
of guided meditation at headspace.com
Joey
that's right download the free headspace
app right now and begin their take 10
program
at headspace.com Joey the show is also
brought to you by datsu saradog
that'susara go to dsgear.com
and check out their extremely high
quality functional gear made with hemp
textiles they have bags skis rash guards
and more when you go to dsgear.com
you're going to use code word Joey to
get five percent off of your order and
go to audit.com and use code word church
to save 10 on all of their amazing
optimization products like Alpha brand
new mood shrimp Tech immune and shroom
Tech sport
why not
why the [__] not
[Music]
and Lee got the old [__] version off
of Stranglehold the the studio album
which is still badass listen to this
[__] thing
before he lost his mind you better show
up early in the morning to Ted's house
[__]
and this is good
is this even Ted Nugent it says it is
because it don't even sound like that
Derek Saint John but who gives a [__]
[__] it's Wednesday June 15th the
Church of What's Happening Now
[__] that's all that matters
strap a [__] pair on cause we're
going deep [__] Darren Carter's here
Lee syatzi and my favorite [__]
Jewish person in the goddamn world and
that's a big honor and that's a [__]
tremendous Army you understand there's a
lot of good yeah there's a lot of great
Jews great [__] Jews out there
representing [__] criminals good
[__] Jews I love them what's up DC
what's up man I just had this visual
what if he because you know he's a lot
younger than we are like you're like he
just pulls up anything he gets like the
Kidz Bop version of something oh yeah
yeah we're like what is this that's not
AC DC it's like that's children
it's funny you were talking about
something real interesting listen
there's two lives you could have as a
comic there's the Darren Carter Joe
Rogan life or there's the Bobby Mendez
life Bobby Mendez was the character I
played on married Bobby Mendez is the
typical comic that comes out here
uh gets a deal he drinks he smokes he
snorts Coke he blows off gigs he that's
who I was becoming and you get a chance
here you blow it and then you just live
on the road
and you're divorced you have nothing at
home and you basically go from town to
town you know doing drugs and getting
chlamydia and just getting sick getting
fatter and is it fun at all I can't see
it being fun if you go down that street
okay yeah there's a lot of comics that
have come out here
gave it to Oklahoma Best you know it
didn't work out for them for some and
they go back and they say then they
start the family and they do all that
stuff a lot of guys come here and they
get jilted
and that leads to you know alcohol or
whatever the [__] it is their
relationships blow because they're not
making the money you're angry and then
you go on the road and you just live on
the [__] road and you have a car and
you put oil in it and you disappear you
have bad credit and you die on the
[__] road and these jerk off say
you're a great comic what other [__]
they say that's not the route I wanted
to go it's really hard that you learn
as a man how high
you have to put into a family
like when I was first married my effort
into my family was 50 it was minimal now
I blow [__] off yeah to be with them
yeah I look at my schedule and I go you
know what that's not necessary that's
not necessary that's not necessary
that's not necessary that's necessary
that's writing I'm meeting that guy to
make money this is the things and that's
what happens when you have children you
know that that DVR box you have and you
tape all those movies you get home that
night you don't do that no more because
that becomes my new part of your life
you know when you're focused on life
everything else it's it's it's very hard
in today's society to have Focus yeah
because you have the computer you have
Facebook you have Twitter you have your
phone right [__] there you you're the
TV you have you know so no more
magazines everything is in your [__]
phone not even in the car anymore and I
love trust me I listen to pod I don't
I'm not I'm if I'm in the car I'm
listening to a podcast absolutely but to
be honest there's all these cars have
Wi-Fi Now cars of all these apps
when I was like I remember being a kid
in the car and you were bought the depth
you hope they crashed the [__] cars
the car my favorite my mom had a station
wagon I had that back seat we've talked
about it before that was better than a
movie for kids yeah I used to be so
jealous when I was a teenager because
when I was a teenager those uh screens
in the back seats started coming out and
I was like mother that would have been
great as a kid but
I don't know I remember being in the
back seat right you're like you try to
like get the truckers to like honk their
horn or or me and my friends would like
be back to pretend that we're smoking
cigarettes and then like the other
drivers would be like those kids are
putting something in there you know and
you're just like paper and you know like
I I can't remember the last time I was
bored you know like yeah because there's
so much as an adult there's so much to
do and then with with all the technology
and stuff there's no down time of like
you know when you're a kid you literally
would like see how far you could kick a
can you know on the way home from school
or something and I mean kind of going
back obviously not the like the Bobby
Mendez type but you spend a lot of time
but you both have spent a lot of time on
the road road now like then you had to
do drive from gig to Gig and you'd be
talking with people now you're flying
you're getting picked up and you go to
the hotel it must be a very different
experience
it must affect the way you do comedy
it definitely does
it listen in 1999
I thought I was going to be Bobby Mendez
were you like it like absolutely yeah
absolutely I should have been headlining
but I was still featuring
Headliners were telling me to knock it
off you've got to slow down you can't
talk to the audience I mean it was just
ridiculous
and I got off the road and miraculously
I met my wife
and the odds changed
I had to pay rent I had to do all this
[__] now and I had to pay
you know what I'm saying these are
things you got to do you know and uh
now I went out and I had to come home
with an amount
you follow me yeah you go out you gotta
come on it's not like yeah in the old
days Leo I mean I'm not kidding I would
I would get
700 for nine shows at The Improv Tuesday
through Sunday
I would take a hundred dollar draw every
[__] night a gram of blow a bag of
weed so there's no money left there's no
money left I was basically doing a gig
for 200 bucks and I would cut Corners at
every level I would eat at the club I'd
take food home at knife in the club I'd
steal beers from the club everything I
did was around the [__] club in those
days and they didn't give a [__] I can't
imagine making 700 a week and spending
five of it on coke five of it I'm going
out and you're in the city anything okay
you land in a [__] City you land in
Milwaukee for the first time right to
some people Milwaukee doesn't seem like
a a big thing to me at that time yeah I
thought I was in [__] Hollywood okay
that's true I don't care what state I
was in I was in [__] Hollywood
on the road yeah
you're like I'm being paid to be a comic
people I'm on the road I'm on tour you
you know it's a little delusional you
know if you're on the road you know
diamond and I don't do it it's not our
lifestyle
for example Burke Chrysler should be
going into every city and sell not from
Wednesday to Sunday because if I had
that type of alcoholic stamina if I
could go out six nights a week straight
and drink with people after the first
thing I do is land in towns go get a
[__] fifty dollar steak that's where
the word spreads that's the gossip
column okay that's the gossip column do
you like cause a scene at the restaurant
no no you act like a gentleman you know
it's [__] of course I'm not a kind of
a scene but no [__] cause they're
singing what's up Milwaukee yeah you
know some guy comes in and he has a fur
no no no he was going to back sit if the
tip is 20 give them 40 because that 40
is your [__] listen you could give
him 40 or you give a [__] a PR
director three thousand dollars a month
and guess whose word's gonna spread
quicker when you give a waiter or 40.
the waiters yeah yeah he's gonna tell
everybody in that bar at least I had
came in for dinner this guy's an old
comedian check him out the guy from The
Longest Yard the guy from [__] the
Church of what's happened now you gave
him 40 [__] bucks that 40 bucks is
[__] gold because he's telling
everybody you came in tonight you're a
funny guy but now people are gonna go he
took care of my friend I'm gonna go down
and pay the 20 and watch them you're
gonna get eight or nine tickets sold
just by [__] him you going in and
dropping the 40 going up to the bar
having a beer dropping another 10 at the
[__] bar that's
that's public relations and that's we I
can't do that no more right I can't sit
at a bar I don't drink I feel like a
[__] [__] drinking a soda with a
[__] lemon and I can't even do that
tastes like Victorious soda you know
what I'm saying like every once when I
got a sudden urge for a Coke but besides
that if I don't want a Coke I drink
water now I don't know why I just the
people telling me how bad diet soda was
I just stayed away from it right but
it's very hard 20 years ago oh yeah
if I was doing the podcast 20 years ago
this would be huge because I'd just be
drinking on here every [__] day and
snorting coke on camera and [__]
getting out of here paranoid and turning
off the camera because the cops were
watching me you know how many [__]
people would watch that today yeah have
any [__] idea some guy some fat guy
sweating doing blow pale
his shirt off I take my shirt off tits
out I think you would do Coke on the
podcast
15 years ago [__] yeah 10 years ago I do
doing bumps in the podcast
there'll be like two shows the podcast
show and then a Coke show why not guys
I'm scared to turn the lights off inside
those doors
any day now some guy's gonna go on
Periscope they start doing [__] blow
and go the cops and turn it off yeah
that guy's gonna get a million [__]
views a week
until he goes to jail no he's not gonna
go to jail because he's gonna do the
last line on camera even if the cops
kicked the door down he ain't got no
Coke
who gives a [__] it's in his body what
are they gonna charge him with yeah
find a way to [__] charge him but
still just do a line of coke at the end
of the night after y'all coked up the
chicks there she sucked your dick three
[__] times on camera no you're a
Christian oh okay you know what I'm
saying your girlfriend suck your dick on
camera but they turn on the Periscope
and she's there foaming from the mouth
you're there with a robot you're all
creepy and [__] you know you like
America good night Joey here and you do
that last gagger
come see me in Milwaukee and you shut
that [__] Periscope off the only
people are gonna come to your show and
bring your coat right you're the [__]
hero it's a different thing you know
it's a it's a different way of
of life so we were getting back to the
the difference between being on the road
then and now like between flying and all
that well that's easy
yeah that
you know you've had I remember having
that moment like I did this College Tour
there was three of us in a van and we
were just for three months we'd be gone
we'd do a whole semester and you would
drive all over the country and I went to
you know I grew up in California so I
was like like you said you're like I've
never been to like Pennsylvania my guy
Pittsburgh you know like uh Philadelphia
this is crazy New York City like you
know just places I'd never been to
before and but then I got to the point
where I'm like how am I ever gonna have
any kind of relationship and like and
you know I only did that for three
months at a time I did it uh for a year
and a half you know we take the summer
off and stuff but
you just and then you picture yourself
like getting older and like thank God
I'm not you know
I broke away from that came to LA and
you know I'm lucky that I have a family
you know it's like some guys never get
out of that
you know it's so it could be so I went
to a club I used to work at the boulder
broker as an opener
when I went through my divorce and stuff
what saved me and how I got my comedy
chops the beginning of my comedy
Chapters at the boulder broker
it was a restaurant on Tuesday nights
for 15 bucks you got a steak a baked
potato and you got the SE three
Comedians and a guy named David Tribble
booked them yeah the triple run okay and
in those days let me tell you something
Felicia came through that the Stanhope
came through there uh
that'd be the guy obilum came through
there they had me maybe seven Comics
that I still see around that I met in
that triple run
and I would look at them every night and
all of them killed you know all the
headliners [__] destroyed the room
but I would look at them go home and
write why I wanted to be like them or
why I didn't want to be like them
you know while you're there waiting to
go up you talk to the comedian you know
are you married yeah
and I would take like a survey in my
head
and when I became a comic at first What
drew me to it was the non-responsible
lifestyle you get a PO Box Lee
you got a room in a [__] hotel for 62
dollars a week you buy blow you drink
beer you write jokes you go out you come
home at four or you have sex that was a
fantasy for me at that time and I lived
it to like
those Miami weeks used to kill me those
Houston Texas used to Count Me In what
way because you liked them from what I
know from what I heard I liked them but
I liked them more because of the drugs
oh okay part of my touring in those days
was for drugs I would do half the year
with Rogan
and I'd be spotless clean not really
after the shows I go back to my hotel
room and disappear in those days and he
wouldn't even bother me because he
that's why I love him he knew what I was
doing and he didn't want to know
and then I would go out by myself where
if I was out for five nights I would get
high four of those nights
until what time in the morning five five
six
seven by the time you wake up it's five
you take a shower you eat something you
still hear the electricity in your head
your sets are [__] garbage
your sets of garbage [__] but because
you're in the position that you're in
your life by the time the second show
starts you got to get a beer in you
the coke would be in my pocket you know
I was going through the thing with the
wife and being broke and you know and
this was my out this was my out brother
but then I went to El Paso for New
Year's 2000 and something happened one
of those Headliners I met
and uh triple that everybody said in
fact he hired me I opened from on a
Tuesday and then he took me to Fort
Collins on Wednesday paid me like 75
bucks but right in front of me this guy
was getting Coke and I was getting Coke
and by that time I had learned in a way
not to do coke with the headliners
at first I would say I could get a fee
and after that I even stopped bad
reputation uh just because you know it
takes your friendship down the wrong
direction oh I see you want the comic to
respect you and you want to respect the
comic I didn't know that I learned early
on that people if you sell Coke and they
look at you like that way it's like that
scene with uh low in The Breakfast not
The Breakfast Club what was the other
Saint almost five when he goes back to
the campus and the kid says to the dog
it's great to have you around we always
get good drugs when you're around
you don't want to be that guy and I
learned my lesson in Denver I got a few
calls sometimes I tried to be cute I'd
show up with a half ounce
and then at the end of the night they'd
go oh you're a comic what oh my comic
you're following me so yeah yeah it just
didn't [__] work on then I came here
and made one mistake and never did it
again
and you're learning your lesson but back
to your original question I would go to
Houston start getting high on if my week
started on Wednesday then
those weeks started on Wednesday okay
I'd be in Houston on Monday night
for the Monday night [__] Open Mic
party
that went to a four or five in the
morning and then Tuesday there was no
show and you got sleep and you
ate a good dinner and you rested and
then Wednesday brother
that party in Houston started all over
and the same in Miami the same when I go
to El Paso El Paso for me was a [__]
yeah
but I went to El Paso for New Year's and
when I was in El Paso that comic I told
you now this comic I forget what his
name is
he was very good comic he did The
Tonight Show two or three times he was
doing well out here something happened
he lost his wife the you know the kid
and he just went on the road and they
were still giving him two three grand
and he would go out every night on the
road where he hung himself
and well I don't know where oh I think I
knew what it is yes he hung himself
somewhere Drake
no no no no no no this guy was like
Brian or Richard or he was an Irish guy
oh and it really dawned on me because at
the time bodies yeah I could tell you to
your face and the listeners I was going
in that direction wow I was going to be
that funny guy that never made it that
way
and died on the road snorting coke and
at that point my life Lee I can't tell
you I was okay with
I was okay with it even after I'd gone
to LA and I had done some I had done one
commercial and one movie
99 the beginning of 2000 I was just out
on the road
and there was a point I was saying why
go back to L.A to do what 15 spots at
the comedy so at least I could stay out
here co-head lamb you know get pick up
momentum and then go back in 10 years
people never come back huh let me leave
it seems like well listen sometimes the
Strategic move is for you to leave
because that's when people think about
you and bring you back hey uh I.E Bernie
Mac not Bernie Mac who who died Bernie
Mac
Bernie Mac moved to Chicago and
everything changed you know there's
something the chick from the [__]
commercials what's the the Geico the
All-State Allstate the girl the girl
that's been doing commercials on for two
years bro yeah yeah bro yeah that girl
was packed up and ready to leave LA and
she got that [__] commercial that's a
five million dollar and two year deal
she shoots a commercial two times three
times a [__] month oh yeah
by now it's just a flat deal
oh okay so you there's two Lifestyles
you take now for me the lifestyle that
works with what I saw early that I never
thought I would achieve was what you're
doing and what I'm doing now
but that has to be a balance because
what happens is
if I took all the work in the world
right now which I can't handle I'm too
old and we have too much going on here
she would leave me within a year
we'd be financially set
but you need that connection at that
same time Sunday through Wednesday you
can't build a family I don't know who
said it but I've heard it a lot that at
a certain point it's like seventy
thousand dollars after that money
doesn't really matter do you I mean I
don't know if it's 70 000 for you but at
a certain point is there just enough
money now
20 years ago there's never enough money
now my family is so important
that I rather live on a [__] budget
and be around her be able to walk her to
school three days a week be able to take
my wife out to Coffee in the afternoon
just the [__] gift that I have to
yeah my wife not being able to work
except doing our paperwork for the
podcast and our paperwork for the chat
billing people just there alone that's
the best my wife's like listen if you
have a child right now and both of you
work
later on there's gonna something's gonna
happen it's because you weren't at the
house at three o'clock
and we've had this discussion on the
podcast before I listened I was raised
by a good parent
but there was a little bit too much
Freedom there so because of that I have
to
be a little tough and now you know the
type of parent you want to be in the
type of family you want to be involved
in if my wife kept that job downtown
we've been making real [__] money
but
you know three days a week should get
stuck in traffic she'd be half dead by
the time she's 48.
so you have to look at that if you have
the opportunity you always have to look
at that in life
because I saw people dying my mom died
from the stress from the bills I got to
do this I gotta do that I gotta do it
it's not working it's not worth it
yeah it's good because I get stressed
out a lot so I I try to work
you know what I'll live a certain way
you know before I was walking here
tonight and I saw some douchebag with a
convertible BMW playing some [__] you
know whatever music
and uh a white dude you know a real only
a white dude would act like a jerk off
like that and said to myself
I wonder how much it cost
to impress people you know
what does it cost I don't think it's
ever over because there's always
something I do have a black Subaru I
don't want nobody to see me yeah yeah
I've never been impressed with that [__]
I know I've never been impressed when
we're walking into a place with gold
chains on I think that the the empty
barrels make the most noise that's just
the Anna Banana fourth grade that's what
she used to say all the time I go all
the way back to [__] 73 with that one
71. empty barrels make the most noise
yeah
I never I only drive with the music loud
when we're on the 134 or the 405 doing
100. in my lines here we never drive
with loud music just driving down the
[__] Street the windows down not the
Street Laurel Canyon yeah oh yeah but
we're doing 90. they said we're cutting
off people I cut some lady off in
Burbank today you know even when she was
mad and she was trying to chase me oh no
she was still 40 yards away from me like
she was just the slowest [__] driver
in the world I'm doing 32. I forget if
it was a tweet or an email but I'll
never forget this he whatever he did
contact me and said I just got I just
got cut off by Joey Diaz on the
one-on-one but I don't even care he
beeped at me
you're gonna [__] hesitate I jump
right in because yeah I'm one of those
guys when you're driving you gotta
jumping out
in 1990 hey I met you right Darren you
were here yeah I'm okay yeah my wife and
I yeah and you were all you introducing
to your wife and I was real impressed
with you because of your wife I thought
you were half a [__] mooc
he's got to be swinging something if you
pulled this Broad and she's beautiful
she's smart yeah wow she was very cool
we talked about Howard Stern which made
me standoffish you know what I'm saying
at that time I'm like a woman I didn't
know it was the demographics of anything
yeah this is how long I know you decent
yeah it was 18 years her and I and you
had a conversation did she smoke
cigarettes at the time no we were doing
something because I wouldn't be outside
if I wasn't doing something relief
coffee you might have no no no we were
at The Improv we were at the old improv
on a Sunday night I actually met her
there Sunday night yeah you guys were
happy I saw you walking down the street
and you know I had just gotten here so
you want to be the nice guy and you're
like Joe this is my girlfriend or wife
and yeah we're talking about Howard
don't worry about my language like wow
Darren did okay I always have a
Christian and look at that I know it's
so funny because I'm not gonna staring
back I didn't know the style Joey didn't
used to tie his shoes and be like Joe
your shoes untied and you're like oh I
got it you know and you just you didn't
care I almost 400 pounds I was like I
could just leave them untied and flip
them on I was on the move those things
smell like a goat you know it's it's
funny another guy another guy that sits
in the chair
and I dropped double digits on you and
you look at me like Jesus Christ we've
been here a long time this is so people
at home understand the struggle
you know last night a waitress hugged me
with the glasses The Comedy Store the
vegan I love it with all my Argent
and how's it going like a one struggle
and she looked at me like you know she's
26. yeah no
you're always [__] pushing ahead
every day you're moving every day you
wake up with a [__] short laundry
list every day you wake up with a short
laundry list yeah
and it's for me it's not it's not to
like impress people or like to end this
when I think of ending the struggle I
think of being rich it's not it's not
like
I'm trying to impress for me I get
envious sometimes and that's something
that like when I see people with those
like that's what I want like it's not
it's not that I'm maybe it is partly
impression there's nothing like
wantingly
listen when I was in the [__] thing a
prison eating Cheetos 11 30 at night I
wanted a Cuban sandwich and bought about
it I'm saying but
there's nothing wrong with one thing
brother yeah the plan is how you gonna
get it
that's the plan we never analyzed that
we never really look at I didn't know
right to where you already have it yeah
you know and then you put yourself in
the bad position
you know ah
there's one car I like anything that the
doors open up upward that's cooler than
[__] you like that oh my goodness I'm a
fat [__] but then again I'm gonna need a
ladder and somebody to help me to get
out of the car those cars alone yeah you
know so you pull up it takes 18 minutes
to go out there that's Hot Wheels
remember we were just Lamborghini you
can just add them to any car add them to
the Subaru I really don't like them I'm
just saying if I had if somebody gave me
a million dollars [__] you got to buy a
car I'd buy a Lamborghini but again I'd
have no yeah yeah yeah because I want to
do 190 in the [__] car I don't want
to do 65 in the 101 to drink you know on
Sundays I'm coming back from the airport
and I see these dudes check out their
1952 Chevys
that pardon 405 North where it's like 22
miles of this like this it's on a grade
yeah that'll [__] you up dog that'll
[__] yeah that's two days of walking
right there a little [__] great you
better pitch a tent [__] I don't
picture you parking your Lamborghini in
front of a you know like a comedy club
and like oh gunning it look at me look
at I don't that's not you I don't you
know I've never ever ever
appreciated that type of behavior and
like never do I want to see myself in
the front of a restaurant
umbrella I'm always in the back you know
[__] it you know uh I never saw myself I
remember the first time I got invited to
a premiere
okay guys I got invited to it for me and
I didn't show up
okay all right now I went to the cast
and crew that meant more to me I saw the
guys that held the cameras and they were
like dog we saw the first cut you were
solid you know what I'm saying yeah
first time was Spider-Man 2. nice didn't
go to the premiere couldn't even dream
about it I just thinking about it gave
me [__] anxiety I could feel my skin
moving they're getting dressed up the
cameras walking in there
just walking in there because I know
deep down inside I don't belong in there
who the [__] wow you were in the
movie who gives a [__] I told Spider-Man
whatever Captain knock but 10 years ago
I would have pulled out a gun and shot
Captain lock you know what I'm saying
you think I would have stood there and
said uh whatever the [__] I said you
gotta go through me yeah you gotta go
through him you're gonna go through me I
would have never [__] said that I
would have said take your guns out this
is New York City shoot this [__]
Metalhead
how cool is that going to be when your
daughter is old enough to to watch
Spider-Man and and really comprehend
like that's my dad that's awesome I'm on
this event still you know I'm on the
fence about Jonah
well it's not going to be a choice after
like the age of like eight
well I don't think those kids are gonna
be looking at Spider-Man 2 from 19
[__] fishes that's the first thing
she's gonna google
you don't think so I hope not
I had a plan right now where I don't
want to know much
until you know it's like two weeks ago
uh Johnny Depp was accused
of hitting that woman
I know the name is I'm not making
accusation tonight you know but a day
later the daughter stuck up fan
because I can't imagine what my
daughter's 10 after I do all this stuff
with her and she turns on YouTube and
hears me telling the story about mugging
a hooker
she's gonna look at that computer
speaker and go it's not my dad yeah I
can't be my dad but that never mugged
the hook around little wig on fire and
then she's gonna go to the [__] turn
to What's Happening Now episode one The
Invention of the flying Jew
I think and that's my uncle Lee in her
mind she's like no yeah but then she'll
put the church on it yeah let you leave
and I'm calling him to find you we're
talking about eating his neighbor's
[__] and all this [__] and she's like
that's my uncle Lee now I'm really
[__] heartbroken they're two Savages
I lived with two Savages all my life
that's the you know that's it that's
what but
on any of those kind of jokes with Maya
because I'm not I don't really go there
but a little bit I do and sometimes my
kid will be like I don't even know what
that means dad what does that even mean
the other day he goes uh because I do
those I like my women jokes you know
the one that he heard heard them uh uh
he goes he goes what does that mean
because it goes I like my women like I
like my Luke Skywalker gripping My
lightsaber with daddy issues he goes
what does that mean why is that funny
I don't know what that means hey I'm
like them I don't know what that means
oh my God
Lee how you doing over there I'm good
you want to take another one you want to
take it right away
no okay we got a mushroom stem coming
pretty soon okay but I think she'll like
it I think I get I don't think maybe not
eight but I think I think this is not
the reason guys
that's not the reason what's up all
right let's pretend something miraculous
happens
and I buy a house somewhere around here
okay okay the closer you get to here
all these kids hmm
the kids whose parents
do something in the business
and they all these kids are rotten but
isn't that High School in Malibu
kids are dropping over there from pill
use and [__] all those high schools
where these [__] rich kids go to
these movie star kids
it's not goodly
never I don't want my child to have to
go somewhere where again somebody's
driving a BMW convertible
16 in high school
and now you gotta go home going what the
[__] is going on here what are these
people pool
yeah I mean right right that that's kind
of not like movie stars but that's a
high school I grew up in kids are
driving and Haskell age and it's weird
but it was uh like can you go somewhere
in North Hollywood because you're not
gonna send her to private school right
I guess maybe you have to in L.A no
there's a lot of schools that are highly
rated in this area really like North
Hollywood whatever there's a school in
North Hollywood where I know the
the uh crisis uh crisis taken around the
private school to put her in that high
school oh wow because then North
Hollywood High is ranked really [__]
high across the country okay
so there's schools around here I don't
want them in the charter school no I
don't want no artistic [__] you know I
don't want no [__] pictures when
they're 15 I need you know you need to
know algebra you need to understand
Logistics that's what you know when you
the other night we were making jokes
that you don't need the [__] the
thing you know the protect the
protractor in the campus you never use
it again when was the last time you did
a comedy gig and I broke out your
program but you know what it made you
think logically at that age yeah you
know it's like smoking pot without
smoking pot well that's actually a new
thing that you're gonna have to deal
with Joey like how frustrating is it now
oh that's all I hear about from parents
now is how frustrating it is to have
kids in school oh Common Core math
things like how the math is totally
different than what we grew up on yeah
yeah and like that's do you ever like
that's something you're gonna start
doing listen I don't even know fractions
I heard a fraction joke two weeks ago
and I'm like Jesus Christ fractions
whatever happens
I guess the fraction's still [__]
around like dancing I thought the fresh
and decapitated I didn't know that it's
still lurking like [__] you know it's
still lurking the
fractions the thing of it listen the
thing about fractions is here's the
thing like you bang your head all your
life to learn fractions and then when
you're 14 you start smoking a pot they
come to you just like that
because everything's a [__] fraction
and eight the quarter three quarters an
ounce follow me yeah I'm not trying to
be cute here yeah tell you the truth all
through your life you struggle with
fractions but Daddy how do you convert
both of them to the both bottoms have to
be equal and all that [__] coming in and
one day when you're 14 you smoke a joint
you're gonna buy a bag
and it comes to you quick a gram a seven
grams is a quarter whatever the [__]
three and a half is an eight 14 grams is
a half ounce and everything is an eight
three quarters a third
you know I'm pretty good at fractions I
have no idea with any of that stuff I I
never understand it like it for whatever
reason for drug fractions yeah the
eighth quarter gram it's too much
that's good to know now
thank you
now DC when did you marry her got
married in 97 man when did the baby come
the baby we waited almost 10 years yeah
we just it was that you know it's a big
decision and and you know you don't just
so for those first eight years yeah what
was touring like to a lot of colleges
you know touring and talk and to this
day I've I've spoken to her every day on
the phone like every day and there's not
a day that's gone by that I haven't
talked to her it's like
um when you were coming back from the
road would you take it for a date during
the week yeah yeah you come back and you
know and we used to play a lot of like
tennis and just you know take long walks
because you you really have to have that
you know in a relationship you know you
have to otherwise you you find you know
you can grow apart even if you're like
gone if you're in town and you're
constantly on your computer or in your
phone and ignoring each other then it's
you know you got to have that connection
like you were saying with your wife it's
like you need to have that where you
guys go somewhere and you do something
like today we went it was great man like
as a family room you know uh to the
arcade and we we all uh my wife and I
and the little eight-year-old boy we
went miniature golfing for the first
time and it was it was awesome we played
video games and you know just just
hanging out eating a little slice of
pizza and spending four hours just
having a ball man it's summertime you
got to do something a little different
you know let me ask you something with
all this [__] that's going on that
happens Saturday night in Orlando God
bless that so
what how do you feel about your child
your wife I mean you're a little more
cautious that you're looking around
yeah you know you think about that
because it's like what they said soft
target it's like
you know
I'm always been you know you know I
carry this flashlight like I'm always
like where's the exits what's going on
like where's my make sure your car isn't
like
too close to the car in front of you in
case you got to make like an Escape
Route or something you know get anxiety
just thinking about yeah yeah it's sad
you know like you said you know you put
yourself on those those popular movies
you know like we're gonna just pop in a
movie I'm like do we have to go you know
let's pick it you know a theater that's
not necessarily I mean it's one of those
things you think about it you know yeah
you live in a society now your child
goes on vacation
gets gobbled by a [__] alligator at a
place where one of the signs no signs I
mean who sees signs when you're on
[__] big games I know you don't even
think about that you know you're walking
around a new [__] Turf you know so
anyway so yeah it just you know it makes
you think there
you know when I walk into school I pick
her up you know I I it just makes you
[__] think that we live in a society
where every time you see somebody gotta
hug them because you don't know if
you're gonna [__] see that person
again but this is what it's really
turned into I know it used to be ten
percent that you giggle yeah yeah after
you [__] with somebody hey good to see
you you know you had to throw 10 drinks
with somebody and also in all three of
us are getting to the con on the way
home you'd say to yourself could that be
the last time I see [__] the fly
I did the dime bar um a couple weeks ago
on Fairfax and across from cantors and
they had the door open uh Adam Hunter
runs that room and there's a you know
the room was packed and the doors open
and uh across the street they had uh a
celebration
and so they were lighting off
firecrackers but we didn't know that in
the com and the Comic Con stage goes it
sounds like there's gunfire out but then
it kept going
and everybody got out of their seats and
bottlenecked to look out the door to see
what was happening and then oh it's
fireworks you know but there was that
moment like when they were all running
that way I was like that's what we've
become yeah you're like yeah you know
I would share my pants guys I'd have a
nervous [__] breakdown
I mean you can't even imagine like 20
years ago I could take the gunfire and
crawl and play [__] Rambo and jump
through a window I think now we just
hyperventilate just a breathing just to
hearing the yeah I think I'd PTSD would
come back I'd start [__] yelling
[__] Vietnamese [__] things yeah
and especially with like he was just
walking around making sure people were
dead that was very scary I said he was
laughing as he was doing it and being
all creepy and it was very scary a
couple weeks ago when I can well I came
back from Omaha Sunday and
20 in the morning my flight was supposed
to land at 9 20. it landed at 9 18 but
it's a short walk to luggage and guess
what when I got the luggage of spitting
that I grabbed it I walked 20 yards
and there was a guy out there
and he flashed at me and I go one and he
goes knock the cat when that girl got in
the cab before me and as I got in the
cab and I always feel dumb when I tell
these stories and I don't feel like an
[__] because I hate when somebody
sneaks up on me yeah I think that I'm
always that sharp to to hear two guys
walking behind me Lisa and ready for
this I gave the [__] guy the luggage
shook his hand
went he went to block me no no I got the
door myself and as I closed the door I
opened my window and as I was putting
the window down two [__] cops were
walking past me Darren I'm not talking
about I'm talking about [__] Nazis
yeah with [__] power wow wow and I
looked at him and I asked the cab
drivers like that today and he goes
traffic I mean already at 9 18 on Sunday
at 9 30. let's pretend it was 9 35 yeah
that was already heavy duty traffic but
when he pulled out I looked at the
section four which is American Airlines
yeah and then it was SWAT wow
so that's a society we're living in so
when you're [__] getting into the
airport now you're [__] neck hair
stick up
until you get to your gate and God knows
what's going on on your [__] gate and
God knows what's going on in your
[__] flight I mean you gotta look at
it this way it's like throwing spaghetti
up at the wall the more things you go to
eventually you're going to get caught in
the mother if you go to a lot of
concerts if you go to a lot of the ufcs
if you go to a lot of this or that who
knows what's and it's not even
what's going on it's the people that we
have here that just go off the radar you
know
the guy was yeah
it comes out that his wife like they
would drive and scope out this gay club
together and then she went with them to
get the you know the holster
yeah it's [__] up because like even
the night before in Florida a white dude
killed I know the merch table right so
and I have a [__] up history with this
we uh you know we all know I spent time
in Israel and when I came back you it's
weird how like the media and the people
around you really influence how you feel
I was a little bit a little bit more
racist I guess towards Arabic people
like in my head but I really feel like
this like when we look back it's gonna
be really bad the [__] we're doing to
Muslim people like obviously Isis is
terrible
but the majority of them aren't and I
but it's to a point now where it's
always think about that if like you're
on a flight and two Muslim looking guys
can walk on
you're not gonna not think about it like
it's just it's weird and that's another
thing it's you're right the whole thing
is because and then some people wanted
to complain but then they were like oh I
don't want to be like you know not PC
like I don't know yeah and then that's
what they're saying with the same
Bernard you know that people were saying
that but they didn't want to be not PC
so it's like what what do you so what
are we supposed to do I know because if
you don't want to
yeah that's weird
last night there was a moment
Lee and I went to a place I had a spot
at the store which I died a slow death
last night that was tremendous
I didn't feel bad no you didn't oh but
you know what I wasn't prepared I didn't
know what to say I didn't know what
temperature the room was you know two
days ago it was a national disaster oh
yeah you don't want to go up there I've
seen Comics go up there and walk the
room half rooms it's not worth it at
this point in my life I don't want no
war with nobody let me go up there and
keep it and Rogan was sitting there and
I'm like and the guy Aaron Gifford who
was killing last night was borderline
gay jokes
positive way and also like oh is it too
quick to talk about gays and brothers
like [__] no go up there and I open up
with a gay joke that dies
that dies something else that dies I
threw [__] eight fastballs nothing
you know and it's it's you come home and
you giggle about it and you feel bad I
woke up this morning I'm talking to my
age and he says listen man I was at the
store last night because I just missed
you because I was there uh last night I
was a dead [__] audience because even
Jake okerson was like what the [__] is
up with them tonight so thank God that
justified my love a little bit like I
wasn't that bad of Jay and a bunch of
other Comics didn't do well so
you know what's funny I saw you at work
uh last week I think it was and you know
what it's great to watch other
Comics that get it you know like
I wasn't there was two rooms at that
club and one room the guys probably even
doing the same stuff forever like by the
book you know a through z and then I saw
you and it was so good because it's like
you're taking chances risks you're
talking about things that you know look
you know what I mean it looks like okay
here's my six things I want to talk
about voting I saw some guy wearing
colored socks and you go off and all
right you know what color it sucks what
if you cut yourself and gets into your
bloodstream come on people I gotta
explain everything and it was so nice to
see that and then you're like oh let me
hit this other thing about cooking or
whatever the time you know what I mean
it was nice it wasn't just like you know
what I mean like like that's I love it
when comedy is like that listen Judy
caught his book again if you're thinking
about getting a stand-up comedy Judy
Carter's book is a must the first one
because she has a list in that it says
talk about what [__] really aggravate
you yeah what really [__] aggravates
you the problem with people is we talk
about what aggravates us minorly
we really don't want to get into the
nuts and bolts because it gets a little
tricky in there but some people know how
to pull it out and walk on a thin line
on it that's me I want to pull it out
let you know I got this problem
but let's walk into the Thin Line a
little bit let's not go either way I
gotta keep you in the Thin Line oh man
that's a weird way of thinking Lisa at
because that's what the comedy really is
it's deep in that [__] hatred and
that pain why do you hate that [__] that
dude that you see in the [__] you
ever see like police movies yeah and the
guy's in the chair and they're asking
them questions you killed them you
killed them awesome they see he sits
quiet for like two seconds then he goes
I did it because I hated my father he
raped me and he sold me to a bunch of
gypsies for thirty dollars
right there if that dude would have
wrote that eight minutes into comedy
yeah he would have got an HBO's back but
who knows off the bat it's that's the
way you're hiding all those years
you think I would tell a [__] story
about mugging a hooker and Lighthouse
wig on fire that was so tucked away in
my soul you know that that thing with
the [__] uh all those stories dog I
tug those things away 15 years ago and I
thought I never needed them again
boy do you need those things to Define
who the [__] you are you really need
those moments and go wow I learned that
from that experience whether it was a
negative a positive experience you got
something out of that [__] experience
if my friend
my friend wouldn't I want to hit
somebody with a he took Santa Lazarus
cane at my party and my mom was on
vacation in Florida and I had a party
and he took this I still think about
that every night there was three or four
Dudes that would have killed this not
with guns but hand-to-hand combat they
would have beat us up to death
this Chris Donovan kid took this thing
and looked at him and said she's not
here but if you make one more move I'll
bust your [__] head with this thing
that kid was pissing his pants
but he picked that thing up and he took
a chance and wow it was my Mother's Day
my mother would have killed me but you
know what from that day I learned
something I don't care what's in front
of you if you stick up for yourself
and you really believe it from your
heart that's why if you go up there and
tell a joke even if it's all [__]
color if you're if your conviction
is real
oh my God they think they're right
it's when you see somebody go up there
and go on with a fake rant Lee Syed has
seen it yeah like only what do you think
uh it looks a little rehearsed boom if
we pick that off
you know we you follow me I see it all
the time I see when somebody already
rehearsed that rant it just came from
that was none I talked about Prince and
the kale oh I didn't hear that that's
what I ended with I loved it because I
was up there and I said you see Prince
he died from those [__] felinals
fentanyls whatever and people were like
oh and I go wait what come on guys what
do you think Prince was at home doing oh
that's right kale Chase and I just
[__] you know it was from my soul
it's the truth are you [__] [__]
what do you think he was doing it at the
pink Gracie Motel Paisley Park what do
you think he was doing that doing
jumping jacks there's bodies under that
[__] building there's women who have
orgasm that he put ticklers in their
[__] and [__] them to death and
play the guitar and drown them with his
nuts sucked you know
are you [__] kidding me I love the
part when you're standing you ladies
need to learn how to suck dick you might
might I got this ugly uncle or whatever
because yeah three dicks I see an ugly
guy suck dick you you ladies are home
eating a bowl of ice cream feeling sorry
for yourself watching Netflix
yeah
it's nice to eat four stars
it's great
oh my God I'm looking at least at least
don't let me tell you something guys at
home if you listen to this if you're a
fan of League I tell you what he's at a
point right now where it's all coming
together
he sees the effort he's putting in
you know what he's doing and now he's
like oh you know what I get it now if
I'm getting up three days a week to see
this [__] lunatic Irish guy at five
at nine o'clock and I don't get out of
that until 9 40. and here's the kicker
Joey
that we do all this [__] and it's a
great workout then at the end he makes
us do 200 swings in 10 minutes
I know Lee guys I saw Lee's face at the
first two times at kettlebell I thought
he was gonna die on me and trust me I I
wasn't sitting next to him till I was
gonna die Lee's doing all this [__] so
finally one day you go you know what
you know what at first anybody who
exercises and sticks to a plan and
really serious about it at some point
goes well what an ice cream doing
and you look at the scale and you didn't
gain any weight and you go what a nice
thing to do with me two nights a week
you know what I'm saying oh I'm actually
pretty nice right next thing you know
you look at the scanning of nine pounds
heavier and your input is still the same
yeah you're even doing 40 minutes a day
on the [__] elliptical but you're
slipping at different places and you go
that's it I don't need this and you
start tightening up for two weeks ago on
the scale you lost the weight you gained
plus four pounds you go that's it that's
the formula now I'm gonna do three
kettlebells a week I'm gonna do this
this is what I need to eat I'm gonna
make grilled chicken and hummus and
stink like a [__] you know like a
messenger a debt I tell them every time
I make hummus bowls just to piss them
off they better hang up I hang up and I
say a prayer for them every [__] time
he tells me because again I promise oh
Jesus Christ yeah it's [__] up you hit
it he hates it because the first oh yeah
he hates it the first I love it with
ranch dressing just kidding
the first mistake I made was getting off
of my fitness pal oh that's a mistake
the person they email me tonight before
I came here
telling me you logged on for the last
190 days yeah if you don't log on you're
gonna [__] and I went and lockdown
and did my menu I was very proud of that
streak and I'm [__] up so I need to
get back on that but yeah that's exactly
what you said happened I just and I saw
it happening because I've lost the
weight like seven times I should be
skinny by now this is what happens okay
because I live it with you yeah so in
your mind this is like I used to treat
cocaine okay listen I love cocaine
I love cocaine I love going out and
getting evil and growing on the floor I
mean some of these monkey I love all
this [__] this is my passion right
I can't do it seven nights a week
but let's say I do it three
nobody anything no nothing right now
obviously two nights a week you and I
get together need stars of death correct
and then there's one night you do them
with Paula from those nights you get up
in two and go to the Yum Yum Donuts and
there's always a by the way there when
you guys go out you go somewhere Goofy
and eat one of those cookies with ice
cream in the middle which tastes like
ass and anyway you put it you know
it's so funny how they reap you sell a
product that's been around since I was a
kid and when I was a kid it was [__]
an ice cream and two cookies yeah now
like it's good Doodles and these suckers
I'm going over there that's good Doodles
they've been around for two thousand
[__] years
I think I put on my first 10 pounds by
eating [__] peanut butter no it's the
doodles
I just look at it my problem was just
because I'd be pretty good during the
day
I know for a fact tonight four and a
half Stars I'm gonna go home something's
going down yeah what goes down I don't
know if there's apricot or Peach well
there might be a couple apples they
belong to the baby but who the [__]
knows I could borrow one of them
I'll drink water for a little while
there's mixed nuts I'll take the almonds
out you that's the high road you're
going the high road that's great you do
that that's not bad after 11 40. I
stopped looking for the peanut butter
yeah and now it's the real test because
there's always two gallons in the
[__] backup and catches an earthquake
I got peanut butter till next [__]
Tuesday I can't do that what anytime I
get peanut butter I eat the whole thing
within like a week peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches listen but I'd rather
do that than eat a steak and fries at
two in the morning I think the steak and
fries might be better she gotta cut a
deal with yourself dog so you eat the
[__] two spoonfuls of [__] peanut
butter you watch uh an old episode
whatever whatever episode The
Honeymooners came on Monday when you go
to sleep that's it I've actually eaten
peanut butter and crackers and watch
workout videos on YouTube because I'm
like I'm gonna do this throughout the
gym
when you're on the [__] road and you
go back to a hotel unless it's the Four
Seasons yeah you know what you got you
got a vending machine and normally I can
read you the vending machine some
[__] memory right now do you know
your favorite letter number combination
all right two it's it's the ranch
dressing uh uh nacho [__] corn nuts
you don't eat those no that's what I'm
saying this is an imagination Lee I'm
just saying that's what's in there it's
not the [__] Branch it's the other
ones what's the nacho cheese chips oh
Doritos Doritos nachos Ranch Dorito cool
ranches wise potato chips wise barbecue
[__] peanuts mixed nuts or spring
vegetable nuts uh the four crackers with
that [__] cancer cheese with the
little spoon in the middle how many
people have gotten cancer from those
[__] crackers the four crackers is
the thing and I'm a [__] I'm going
delicious I used to love this oh
everybody's like those things that's the
fun that's how they first injected in
you two of those [__] crackers I
believe it grows or your immune system
blows it up think of that cheese that's
not [__] cheese remember when you
just get it to eat the cheese and throw
the crackers away that's when you know
it's a little red spoon yeah with the
little red spoon and you save the Red
Spoon for it like Someday I'm gonna do
something with these bones
I don't know if they had them when when
you guys were kids but dunkaroos they're
like cookies you can dip them in icing
oh my gosh that sounds good it's like
the same thing it's like the crackers
and the cheese but because I used to
make cakes and not bake them you
understand me I would just eat the
[__] oh the first thing in the mix
everything everything and I this time
one time I threw the reefer mix in there
ate it all the bowl I slept for three
and a half days you know we're gonna buy
a better fit combination [__]
everything he said with the raw eggs in
there oh yeah who gives a [__] it's like
Rocky yeah exactly who is a [__] you
want to be how you think
they always cook they always fried those
[__] things people used to drink them
like like just him like a clam
that's crazy
you want to bake a cake it'd be way
better
you don't have that hour it's right here
it's right now that's why I like the
peanut butter you know
my life boy your shit's like I could lie
to everybody and tell you I was a mess
when I moved into my wife's house it
took about four years for me to come out
of this uh fog
one day I looked at him like what am I
doing
I'm giving all my effort to this this
and this and where am I going I got to
be get given effort to my house and it's
something clicked into me
and then it just became Tighter and
Tighter and she became a piece of me and
she understood me and I understood to
her and
um it really balanced out the comedy it
took a little Focus off my comedy but I
kind of needed that that time well I
would become insane there's a point that
you have to uh push yourself away from
the business I had already gotten a
movie or two I had already done comedy
at The Comedy Store for [__]
six or seven years you know if something
was gonna happen it would have happened
what the [__] am I doing with my life
let me go this girl digs me let me put
effort into this woman and then we ended
up getting married and whatever now we
have the child whatever
and now I found the balance I never
thought they could beep when I listen
guys I lied to a lot of [__] young
kids
I lied to a lot of young kids 10 years
ago because I told them that you can't
be a good comic if you're married with a
child
and boy did I give bad advice to a lot
of people
because I know the commitment level it
needs to become to come out here and
really push [__] through
it's tough enough that you started as an
open micro in your town and then you
started I'm saying and then somebody
liked you and took you on the road and
you came back and featured for a year
and a half
then Montreal told you to go [__]
yourself but this club in San Diego do
you own Elijah and he thinks he wants to
manage you so you move out and now
you're in the [__] game
now you're in the game that six years
you just did that was basic training
[__]
this is where people crack once they
jump into the game they look at this
place and they know after a week if
they're gonna fail
I know a thousand stars that could have
been stars because you know and we've
had this conversation a thousand times
but it's so weird how you evolve once
you have the family
once you have somebody at home like it
really changed for me in 2005 and it
just got better and better and better
because I found the balance
and like I always say I know how would
it takes to lose a family I did that so
from that I learned how to not lose a
family and there's a different level of
commitment even if you're just sitting
there for a year you think you want me
to lie to you people
for the first year that Mercy was born I
would sit there and my [__] skin
would crawl
because in my heart I could have been
doing a thousand [__] things
to help this house
but you know what I learned that the
best thing I could do to help this house
is to sit that way and watch Bubble
Guppies
and what [__] you know all those
other shows and I respect the [__] out
of you guys like Josh Wolf
can I like [__] Christchurch
Tom Papa these guys have [__]
gaffigans got four [__] kids no and
you gotta go out every night and bang it
out with Savages and write material and
[__] you know that stuff Rogan that's
tough
I see Rogan's flight [__] schedule if
he's not doing comment he's doing USC
that's four or five [__] weekends a
month
you know on top that is on your family
if you're not connected
because I know dudes who come home on
Monday morning guess what they do for
two days they sleep I don't want to be
like that that's not what I wanted at
all at all I know especially if you're
leaving the next you're like yeah
I don't have time to sleep I need
sunshine
it's hard like today I had four hours of
sleep and I'm like all right let me just
push through this and do this and it's
and I'm glad because that's what you
want to do you know the family time
creating those memories and just you
know enjoying each other's company and
it's like
you know and I gotta say
um
not only do I know you you and uh I'm a
listener of this podcast and and uh
it's funny like for like the listeners
like you know I also am a fan like
there's only you know there's not that
many podcasts I listen to I mean you
know that but I'm this is my main one of
my main podcast I love this podcast and
we had a family you know tragedy back in
December my mother-in-law passed away
and you know I mean that's a shocking
thing when that something like that
happens it was out of left field and you
don't want to believe it and it's you
know and then my wife had to take my son
and go up North and take care of
business and you know just try to make
some sense out of it
and I had a couple hours
by myself and it's like I was like let
me just go for a walk I just got to go
for a walk and just kind of deal with
like what just happened and it's and you
just
for for some reason I brought my iPod
and I for Comfort I put on
um the Church of What's Happening Now
and
man it's not to be a psycho but like I I
actually was like you know it was great
to like just have that comforting talk
and I actually was you know I'm crying
I'm looking like a you know like
listening to this podcast and and there
was this one part where you said
something like every day I get out of
bed and I'm you know I'm above ground I
think my lucky stars and I love my
daughter and it just it wasn't just like
meaningless words like it really meant
something to me right there and man that
was the best thing to hear and and to
have that common that that bond that we
you know we have is is a Entertainer and
as people and and I remember like
sending you a message like right away
and you got back to me like you know
right away and it was just it felt so
good just to have that man you know
because I I at that time I didn't know
if I could even talk to anybody or tell
anybody what happened you know like I
was like let me just
you have a couple hours just you know by
myself and get out there and walk and
when people talk to me about the podcast
you know the last three years it's very
hard for me to digest the things they
say to me I can imagine this is just too
[__] crazy [__] yeah talking
[__] people say things to me and I get
many anxiety
I really do I am like look at this
[__] [__] he listens to us and he's
gotten something out of the show would
you learn would you learn how to roll a
joint you [__] idiot yeah and then I
started thinking I started thinking
about being you know and the things I
depended on
little by little I started getting it
you know in those days I was [__] up
listening
happiness to me in those days was
putting on a Black Sabbath now I'm as
sad as that sounds and listening to that
[__] stuff that gives Lee anxiety at
16 you know those words I found some
warped in those [__] words and yeah
you know so I understand that mentally
and the connection or maybe we take you
some more of the vulnerability that we
show sometimes because
that's it you know I wouldn't I didn't
want to do this to just be a [__]
announcer yeah I wanted to do this to
have a voice every week but also
tough
people when you're down it's tough to
look at people and go wow you know he
did this this is it's tough for a person
to imagine that they can do that and
that's what I want people to know with
this show I always have different type
of people on this show
but they all have the same thing they
stuck to something yeah it's really nice
too you and I have been talking about
Freedom the last seven years
Freedom has been big because we came
here when there was no freedom
what do I mean by no freedom to the
people at home no Freedom was Darren
Carter would come to me and say dog
you're an orphan yeah listen I want a
rather pilot about an orphan okay and
about two orphans and a [__]
orphanage who run a gambling casino
whatever the [__] well I'm just making
hypothesis yeah
next thing you know we write this out
yeah we take it to your manager I'm a
bum I don't have a manager take it to
your manager manager loves it he has a
writer who contacts HBO
we take it everywhere they love Darren
they love Joey they love Lisa but guess
what nobody wants to buy it and it's
done well guess what that's it Darren
goes home he looks like a mooc he told
his wife he was buying her a house in
the top of the mountain going there yeah
now he's got to get real Gods they're
gonna stay in that little Shack in
[__] Laguna Beach and share a car and
you know fun
not anymore
Darren could get a different writer we
manage it and take it to Netflix and
Netflix don't want to get the Hulu
and a fool of them I think it's a few I
refuse don't want to think it should
show time their Showtime don't want to
and eventually you have more Avenues and
guess what and if Darren really really
believes in he could do a Kickstarter
with a [__] real CBS producer
tried to sell it to
CBS which never happens of course and uh
but you spend the [__] 80 000 and you
shot a Pilots your accomplishment you
put twenty thousand into it but
Hollywood didn't like your idea
that's the options we have now
so for years you and I have been
speaking about CDs
and we've been talking about how Lee and
I one night took a [__] thing took it
down to Bray I rented one I rented one
next thing you know I got a [__] CD
that's number one in Canada or whatever
we and I couldn't figure it out um
so we did it again 18 months later that
wasn't as good as the first one
it did well
and then we waited two years and we did
it again
and that one was Sensational and
our friend taped this for us the whole
thing but here's the beauty of it that
for years nobody liked me
nobody anymore I existed I just put them
on iTunes
and guess what I got a revenue on it and
I don't get a great percentage if
anybody deals with iTunes hole put your
music on iTunes and see what you get out
of it [__] suckers and they take a
percentage out they bang you on the side
they bang out in the [__] head by the
end or get that piece of paper get up no
please don't touch a drawing you get a
piece of paper and all the [__] ouch
it's like that one uh Ralph cranum scene
with Norton he rips it down he has one
piece of paper left he puts on his
forehead same [__] thing they take
you down but at least you have that
freedom to do that yeah when you and I
got here in 2003 it [__] sound four
records and Johnny's record Shack and
yeah boo-boo boo they didn't sign you
yeah pull out a [__] CD remember that
yeah man I showcased for uproar yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they
didn't like me and [__] and then [__]
the dude from Vietnam came to you and
then he goes you want to shoot us
anything I'm Gonna Give You 33 dollars a
minute you tape up at the ice house I
know and then next thing you know people
calling you from truck stops man yeah I
saw your CD and [__] yeah South of
San Marino
no I heard that you know this is what I
heard you know Jeff Foxworthy that you
might be a redneck that it was in all
these truck stops and I heard that one
of those tapes he only got 400 bucks for
the whole thing and come on that's one
of it it's he's the you might be a
redneck guy and that was in the 80s and
that's what he got and then these are
the record companies back in the day
like oh I got a record company but then
the comics start you know they're like I
never got really paid for it and I'm I
have to pay like you know six bucks I
gotta buy my own copies for like six
bucks a piece
and I'm like guys you have no idea yeah
you know when you hear about the music
industry and you hear about Black
Sabbath who had bad deals and management
who stole money
I'm the one time
these guys came to me
and we showcased at the ice house and
they loved everything and then we showed
up and they we signed all this paperwork
for the Armed Forces remember that what
was the name of that and we all shot and
they gave us 1500 flat what was that
when they gave us a thing and an address
and they were gonna sell 150 000 units
and that went through we were going to
get an additional ten thousand dollars I
waited for about 12 months and now I got
The Longest Yard maybe even longer two
or three years and I got The Longest
Yard
and I [__] the attorney I hired I got
him on it and he was like this is the
craziest thing the paperwork exists but
these people are ghosts but he goes
guess what I find out
he goes they didn't sell 150 000 units
to my Armed Forces they sold 400 000 to
the Armed Forces wow and for years I
bump into soldiers and they go hey I
bought your tape over in Iraq
um
Garcia it was like six guys I remember
what was on the [__] thing I made fun
of an Asian girl I told him to suck my
dick oh yeah horrific horrific okay
Lopez I think I saw it at the drugstore
but yeah eight years ago oh please it
was at Walmart one time Kentucky I saw
it in [__] Walmart in 2000 something
I had a heart attack they're still
getting [__] top price for at 7.99
and they had this corporation that
turned into another corporation that
turned up another Corporation I got so
[__] mad I tell you how mad I got
what the cocaine did to me Darren car oh
I threatened to sue the guy from The Ice
House because he cut the deal there oh
he's gonna have our [__] back you
know what I'm saying it's like if I say
I'm gonna have a pound of wheat it's the
same [__] reason so I got really
pissed but then I got over it life moved
on and I grew the [__] up
sometimes you gotta grow the [__] up
people that's it and get your life
together let me read some shout outs
here I know you got a spot somewhere
where we're at I'm head over to Flappers
and work on that next CD look at you I'm
gonna give a shout out to my main man
Hue Fitzgerald bob la Lingus in Chicago
uh my girl ookie spooky AKA T Winkler
Keith Arizona Greg and Lynn up there in
Seattle Jared Moss Mike Davis Grim
[__] dog you know what I'm
saying and my main man Christopher
showed me his bug today whatever David
Christian's a nice [__] dude I love
that [__] with all my heart
it's it's Wednesday night already Jesus
[__] Christ it's June 2016. can you
believe that
2016 but it's June 15th
it was just June [__] fourth three
days ago
or at least that's what it feels like it
feels like time is moving uh
quickjack
this guy told me an analogy about that
because I had a birthday and he goes he
goes life is like a toilet paper roll at
first there's a lot of toilet paper but
then as you get older and then it spins
around faster and faster and then
there's like less and then
you're out of toilet paper was it like
the janitor
no it's just a guy that I knew I think
I'm not doing no more edibles
I told the surgery
why not I think I'm going cold turkey
just smoking yeah I'm starting to get
anxiety about the surgery without the
edibles
I can't imagine me going home or to a
hotel one night sitting there and
thinking about [__] knee surgery no
surgery or no do you have a way to stop
back because sometimes I have anxiety
too
yeah I got a way to stop then stop
eating edibles
in the [__] hope Artois goes away
because I'm telling you when I hate
edible's late it's not good when I go
home I go like a late heartbeat in the
middle of night
I'm late hurt me what do you call those
things regulations
yeah like something that plays the drums
in there I gotta get up and walk around
and wake my wife up to watch me for two
minutes I gotta drink some water and
turn on the TV and breathe and then
everything's all right but it's not
[__] edible I know it is it's not
just my heart or some playing tricks I
mean I got a tank in there you guys are
looking good though man this exercise is
really it's working it's like you said
you go up and down I joined a boxing gym
uh last September and there's something
about going to a place and sweating hard
you feel incredible man like stuff I
never used to do before I used to just
take like mild walks and Pull-Ups here
and there and but when you're jumping
rope and you're like hitting the bag
it's like the best you know that that
will get rid of anxiety because my
underwear was sweaty today yeah I've
never had that before it's kind of cool
honey like the shirt
your whole shirt is just soaked yeah the
shirt's always drenched but the
underwear today was I was like whoa I'm
doing something that's what happens
I heard years ago sweating was good for
you
I heard you know 30 000 [__] years
ago when I was a kid that that's as you
get old it's the most important thing to
sweat there's days where you take a day
off the next day you [__] yeah it's
like the next day you work out and
if you don't sweat you could smell what
you hate two days ago
it's weird if I if I ever don't work out
the day after edible I'll be high pretty
much the next day if I have to come
force yourself to work out otherwise it
stays in your system oh yeah now and now
you know how to get it out now you know
that one hour on the elliptical and some
kettlebells and everything is out from
the night before the salt and that
lizard you eat
the [__] uh the cotton [__] you want
to talk about that you were talking
about last night which is just
disgusting I wanted to get him
marshmallow fluff this is what this
guy's [__] eating I don't wanna know
I don't eat it because it's not like you
rub it on your toes I don't go to my
house I don't have my house I'm just
saying
I'm just saying Mercy should have a
Fluff remember
what about cotton candy you like that or
no that's always been his fingers get
dirty and [__] all that effort they walk
around with sticky fingers and even if
you rub them with cotton now they
attract stuff flies like Spiderman you
get home you have glass and rocks and
it's [__] disgusting I hate all that
[__] I never fell for that stuff when I
went to a carnival in the east coast you
buy those [__] zeppolis with the
sugar on them that's my favorite you get
a nice [__] you know whatever have
you tried the donut cheeseburger not in
a million years dog
I don't know what have you tried now no
I can't bring myself to eat me and Paul
are thinking about it we went to the fan
and we went to Yelp and we saw them and
they got good reviews and I don't know
we we thought about it and then we
walked away and when the whole way on
the fine we thought to myself we should
have stopped and get the [__] out of
here I knew you were thinking about it I
love that impression of you oh please
every [__] Monday I get this the real
reason I couldn't do it is the only size
they had was the triple one sure that's
you man that's you I just wanted one
just one bite let's see what it tastes
like yeah you want Paula could have just
put it in between years and met in the
middle
I like that spaghetti from that movie
you guys don't know it's actually
delicious I could actually see them
doing it and bumping into each other in
one bite in the other tongue and [__]
like crying I'm not crying I don't know
what I did I love you yeah
fuckingly uh
tough for the nails ladies and gentlemen
kettlebell in it 800 900 milligrams a
night I got them in basic [__]
training you understand me most people
doing 10 milligrams down 9-1-1
stabbing their wife jumping off a
building not least I had I got him in
the office [__] banging it out like a
[__] Soldier
the [__] Lee so Darren Carter
you finally took the chance this is what
number CD my fourth album and how many
years uh that's the thing the first 10
years you're like you don't even think
you had to have a record deal so my
first one came out in 2000 after even
back then you're like you I remember we
did some one-nighter gig back in the
early 2000s you go I'm proud of you you
deserve a CD a lot of these guys they've
never because at that time I did The
Tonight Show and you know they haven't
they've been doing comedy for six months
and they're like I'm gonna try to record
this you know so I did this I was
petrified Darren Carter you were
petrified I was respected guys like
listen yeah for some reason I get into
comedy and your first Big Goal besides
getting a TV show or winning the Johnny
Walker red yeah competition yeah or
there was a search competition and also
with Doritos Lee I'm dropping knowledge
on these [__] they don't
remember when you were living in
Michigan yeah right and you sat there
and I jerking oh I'm like what do I want
I want that blonde in Hollywood but what
how what's gonna Elevate me there what's
going to elevate you there is you had
options I'm talking about this these
were your goals in the 80s to be on a TV
show or 90s I'm 90s yeah be on a TV show
and pop or movie and pop you know it's
tough to get cast and when you live in
[__] Utah for a big movie I'm just
I'm just using a state beside California
no offense to anybody
or you uh have a sitcom of your yourself
or a big time album
like a big timeout my people you went to
people's houses and every yeah every 10
houses you went to the drink beer four
people had that album and everybody said
Put it on yeah you know and and then you
then about six months later you get home
stoned then you'll be going to your TV
and also like Ruby Calamity from Las
Vegas and you see that guy yeah and you
go oh [__] I'm staying up but when you
saw him there was another guy that was
even funnier than it yeah and now you
became his fan too
you know but that was the highlight that
albumly yeah when I bought an album I
walked home in an hour there was a
[__] album so
I start comedy never in my mind
what I consider doing now never I get to
The Comedy Store never considered it
wasn't even in my [__] I would see
guys that got albums and I would go hmm
that motherfucker's doing a good job and
then something happened the word got out
that you could sell merch on the road
okay and that's fine every man for
himself I don't put nothing down
and next thing you know everybody's
selling merch
at that time the First Merch was really
CDs this is around 98. people started
selling CDs I got it and I'm I'm at that
point Shimmer was selling to see these
yeah uh
uh Bobcat Goldthwait Margaret Cho uh not
Nick depaolo but guys like uh there was
a handful of guys Carlos Mencia and then
it kicked up a level again and now
something happened the B room
Comics started doing CDs and guess what
happened they made a shitload of cash
from 98 to 2000 then people caught on
and all of a sudden you started going to
shows and kids that have been doing
comedy for three years are going hey
darrenkai here's my CD and you're like
yeah I don't even know I'm coming in
like three years and you couldn't judge
the CD of the material yeah but at first
I was taken aback like three years you
better pay your douche before you could
put a CD out
so that was my train of thought that
something had a you had to put some Ward
time in then they got a point by 2002
Lee everybody had merch
everybody had merch DMC had a [__]
bumper sticker you [__] feature act
had a [__] trombone and the [__]
uh the the the the other guys had a CD
and a t-shirt then Carlos men see it
took it to level up yeah he started
taping the shows
charging you and sending you the show
for the personal show that night like
that show that night which I thought was
[__] brilliant at the time that's 99
2000 2001 2002. I didn't consider doing
my first CD
so after Spider-Man 2 that I really
needed the money to snort coke if you
look at the album cover I'm pale as a
ghost wow pale as it goes that was a
month away from dying lately like those
pictures from that CD
I was uh it's a shame it's a [__]
shame
can we yeah so two so 2000 was the first
one and then I didn't even think about
it for a long time I was like and then
and then you know what they give you 750
and tell you they send you money no no
for that one I did I I uh I
um I had some help but but they really
did it they helped me out a lot uh it
was the first album Shadyside it was in
Monterey you know those two brothers I
don't know if you ever work for those
two guys are they still around I think
so but I don't I don't know I haven't
gone back I've gone back a few times but
you know
um and and the reason I did it there is
they kept telling me you should get a
record we'll help you we'll help you up
the recording equipment we used to be in
a band we used to tour Canada will help
you and they actually helped me they it
you know but then I was like I don't
really want to do this thing and and
then you know 10 years went by but then
uh you know Pandora got popular Spotify
all these things in our apps our
smartphones and then in 2010 I'm like I
gotta put another album out because I'm
tired of my old stuff being on SiriusXM
and then it was a thing where it's like
this is kind of this is cool man because
on the way to like doing a special and
also there's stuff I'm like let me work
on material get it out there and and you
know so then I came up with another
album that last one that stay at home
stripper album and that and then then
only a year and a half went by and then
I was able to put this one out and this
one comes out June 20th it's it's great
the party continues and it's like it's
able to like
you know
I read this great quote it said without
a Finish Line a goal is just a dream and
so to be able to say you know and I hear
you do that too you're like I'm gonna
make sure that I'm gonna do this thing
by you know this date October or you
know it gives you something to work
towards so it gives you something so
we're not just out every night like you
know or on the road or whatever just
like here's my same old jokes and you
just you know how many years I threw
away in L.A for not planning years years
that if I would have had the mentality
years later I know I would have been a
killer in those days a little up in less
passive I would have known how to treat
management and agencies better things
would have been different I would have
tried to push I would have worked a
little cleaner just to get to the
festivals do you know what I'm saying
there's a mistakes you making you learn
from but uh
what are we talking about I'm stoned on
the [__] no no just the goals and how
to oh yeah otherwise you're just out
there once you figure out like a plan
like I have a plan every week whether
I'm on the road or home people real
quick I'm sorry to say this but people
are lucky to have Joey Diaz in their
life you know what I mean like okay
because right now you're the mentor that
people needed we all need and it's funny
I'm a grown-up and I still but I still I
love hearing when you say Mondays get up
early Tuesday I can't figure out I wish
I had someone telling me this when I
[__] talk to somebody when I talk to
somebody
okay listen let's get it out of the way
again for the 80th time
boom get out
of high school
join the service figure out some type of
[__] College Way yeah go to college
for four years come out back on the
service
retire in the service and come out going
to law school while I'm in the service
and come out and be a [__] attorney
that was the original [__] dream okay
that's you you have a [__] whatever
there was no goal when you were a kid
you say you're going to be a fireman
yeah
all of a sudden here you are yeah you're
out and you
but now you have to be self-motivated
you got to do something because people
who come from great backgrounds and go
to college
are missing Little Things
and they don't know that this is you
know everybody goes to college I figured
it out man
I figured it out while I was at the
University of Colorado with the felonies
going wow so what am I gonna rush for
to get any type of [__] uh uh degree
that means I'm gonna have to do
something with it
that's a scary thought and Lee at that
time I was a [__] grown man dog I
can't imagine what it was like for you
to graduate and go wait a second things
change mom's not gonna help me I mean I
gotta for a year or two but this is real
and what if you don't like it what if
you're like oh I always that's what
happened I saw people I saw that happens
to a thousand people you get out of
there and the investment you're like
Jesus Christ now I'm in a hole for
something I finally go get the job and
it's not the [__] job I thought and
that's what it is it's not that I hated
it it's just that it's
when you go when you're going to those
schools they pump you up and and all
you're thinking about is your dreams and
you get there and you realize oh wait
confessionally
start the confession yes sir I couldn't
imagine
going to Anderson for four years
or NYU or any other entertainment
[__] School Syracuse or whatever I
can't even imagine
and for somebody to ask me to get them
coffee at least I had my ego would break
considering of what I thought I had just
done
for some [__] mooc to say listen Diaz
get me in and my partner coffee sweet
and don't [__] it up
especially when you're making let's say
2 000 a month and 200 of that [__]
dry cleaning another 100 goes to parking
uh I was gonna say 200 just goes to the
student loans oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah
I always thought that going to college
meant when you walked out something big
happened and that's why I always envied
that lifestyle I always thought that wow
that guy's got something going on
because he went to college and here I
was getting the same education in a
[__] different way with a different
type of Target you know and as Comics
you know you come out here and you're
very passive you don't know what the
[__] to do until one day you go why am I
paying this much 10 yeah and this month
ten percent I got better ideas anyway
these are all my [__] ideas when you
come out I want to manage it you think
this guy's gonna meet with you for
coffee once a week ago because okay so
how's the ACT going how's the [__] uh
touring going let's go over your
schedule here you don't like Tuscaloosa
let's get you a [__] personal jet and
fly you in like the way they did a La
Bamba and then let's do this and let's
no guys they don't do that at all and if
they do do it you don't know I want
people at home to know yeah young
comedians who listen that I hope you
don't think that when you come out here
they meet with you and they say all
right listen we want you to wear a
purple shirt from now on you know we
want you to go on a diet I did the
stupid okay my first big time management
okay back in 97 they had um they were at
the Century City those Twin Towers those
top floor I mean it's fantastic and and
the same building that Ron Howard you
know I mean he was right next door and I
was like looking out the window like
damn this is big time and I was just
like so excited and they you know they
got me some college gig back then 1200
bucks and do you know like when it got
done they booked the travel so the
flight and they got me a limo a limo to
take me from the airport to this college
gig like the travel was 900 bucks and
then I had to pay my commissions and I'm
like what is this music unlimited oh
that's the car service even the limo guy
was like he's like it's hard to navigate
these you know these these Corners to do
this college campus and I'm like
as my management set this up man you
know and at that time I was still
teaching traffic school on the side and
I was like it's traffic it's still
around the comedians still teaching I
don't know but I know they I haven't
taught it since 97 but I I did get a
ticket and I and I just did it online
you know about eight years ago I'm like
that was kind of cool to go online and
just like you know actually I I went as
a student one time just to see how
someone else would teach it and I'm like
man that's pretty brutal just sit there
for like eight hours and listen to
Somebody talk about stop lights and
changing lanes and try to be cute yeah
yeah and you start picking up a certain
act because you know it works over and
over again yeah until one guy comes in
and says hey I got in the UI eight years
ago and you still had the same act like
I [__] up at the store I [__] up at
the DUI room yeah what the [__] is my
career going yeah one thing man I admire
you for
balancing your career man I admire you
because I gotta tell you you're out a
lot more than I am at night and I
[__] admire that but I am
I am wiped by 11 o'clock like I really
gotta work I'll also get up really early
I mean I get up early too but I go back
to bed yeah I think you stay up I gotta
you know once I had the nose surgery and
I come out I gotta tune it up I've been
writing but I tell you nothing's been
working I've been having brutal reasons
I saw you working and I know that [__]
I'm gonna have to bring Lee with me to
tape me I know that you know what I do
is I bring this phone out and I tape
especially my short sets like the ones
are like 10 minutes or 12 minutes those
I can listen to and I'm like okay today
I'm gonna work on the boxing bit I'm
gonna work on a bit about my wife those
things about my son you know and then I
and then not then that's that's part of
the work and then the other part is
sitting down going to a coffee shop
listening to it which is we don't like
to do oh man and taking those notes and
being like okay I did this that I can
tighten that up I can you know and I
gotta be honest this is the best time to
do it in our careers because it's easier
now when you're young it's you know
you're what's funny what's funny now
this stuff just comes because we you
know you already have your comedy
receptors up and you're like boom boom
boom I can say this joke my comedy
resistors are getting [__] old
I've got an anxiety attacks two times I
have a breathe out of my nose once
thinking about how close this special is
and how I'm 42 minutes away from the
[__] goal I gotta have an hour and
five to shoot a 60. yeah they could cut
it down to 48 which says some new world
to keep me tighter and bang it out but
at this point I got 22 minutes or
something material that
uh I'm telling you man just so I gotta
really I got anxiety about that comedy
material comes so easy to you Joey I
know it does and and people you have
things that you do that people like like
you would you know it really looked like
you had six bullet points when I saw you
like you're like voting and it was like
funny and and you're like I can't vote
you know and seeing you guys vote
you know and I was picturing like those
those moms at the farmer's market with
the tattoos on their arms that you like
to talk about and you know and some guy
whatever like he had his man bun I voted
today you know I want to punch him in
his [__] face oh my God it was
hilarious dudes yeah yeah yeah it works
that morning just like I looked at them
and I was like wow
wow we're in deep trouble and they
walked into the voter like
they're like nah man but that is still
in the [__] game you got some movies
while you were here you know
you don't have
one thing about guys like us is we lost
the smell of desperation
which is a gift just in itself after a
certain time here you don't want to be
at a certain Listen if you go down to
the Improv on Wednesdays you know you
know Marco Giovanni's there who's Mark
over Giovanna the great director the
next thing where you find yourself down
and when you see the like the [__]
muck being down there and also one day
he go up to me go Marco Giovanna I'm a
big fan of yours he's my CD it looks
like he was thinking he puts on the
table and he walks away from me you want
to go and put a gun in your mouth you
know how many Comics I know I did that
a lot Lee
that found out like a director was going
to be at the Improv on a Tuesday night
or at The Comedy Store during the black
show okay and they linger in the
hallways and then they give them like a
copy of his short film and [__] I used
to see it all the time and then it gets
thrown away right later on somewhere as
soon as somebody grabs them and take
them to the bar yeah as soon as I gotta
go pick up the drink they go what are
you [__] kidding me come here for a
second yeah you want this they're always
trying to give it away to a wage is it
you want this I know it's in the weights
like yeah it's a friend of mine get the
[__] out of here I'm gonna bring that
home it's you know we all did that we
all did something that silly and now you
go to The Comedy Store and you see the
guys doing it and it brings back
memories of how you don't buy the
[__] no more Nothing's Gonna really
help you don't get to help you coming
here every night six nights a week
putting out your CDs you know not
selling your [__] soul I got a Disney
classic movie so I can't curse on stage
anymore you know I can't really be a
[__] uh whatever because they don't
want me on the show for act
that's only you know that's not even
happening anymore with Comics they know
who they're hiring now it's a different
[__] game we say yeah don't just sit
there and stab me what the [__] up I'm
good what's up what do you got planned
this weekend what's happening with you
you look a little down no you haven't
seen Paul all week I could see you
starting to break donut hamburgers look
at you yeah hold on a hamburgers
go ahead what are you gonna do oh that's
what it was the lady in the [__] where
they had the spaghetti and they want
them in the middle
tomorrow I don't know right now all
right nothing I'm gonna go Friday
I finally have kettlebells and regular
work right
when do you see Paula maybe Saturday
maybe so he's gonna come out of the
house for an hour
eat something you don't want to
read of the [__] whatever when she
gets drug tested so she can't do it
that's it it's over well yeah
she can't do that
[__] lawyers are probably the only
people who drug test listen I know
lawyers that smoke more pot than you and
I well yeah I'm sure once they get the
job they get the job yeah I see how it
works that's it you know beating Stars
by yourself you just feeding yourself
you know you'll sit there in front of a
stone to the gills with your new head
dude you're looking sharply God bless
you I'm so happy you stuck with it I'm
happy you like Dave that's big and today
I was thinking about why I go to jujitsu
like how enthused I am about going like
today I was having nah I wasn't having
no bad day today it was just cloudy you
wake up in that late the last couple of
days it's been cloudy yeah so it throws
you off
another thing you find yourself in a car
going to do something that you're not
good at but you're gonna go sweat and
you're going to go giggle a little bit
they're going to take your mind off so
when you come back to that your mind's a
lot stronger to deal with that joke or
whatever dude I love it it's like the
best when I come back the first thing I
do is log into jiu-jitsu.com or whatever
that's called bjjournal.com my friend's
web page and then after I log on there I
go on my notebook and every time when
I'm driving home from Jiu Jitsu to the
house I got something to say in my head
and I got about 18 of those things which
if two of them work for the CD for the
special I'll be very happy
just a little [__] observations you
made you know what I'm saying whatever
so when does the CD get released there
in Connor it's called the party
continues comes out June 20th it's uh I
I took advice and did a pre-sale so
people can if they get it like they can
buy it right now and then they instantly
get uh like a free track right away you
guys know I wouldn't have them on here
if he wasn't family number one number
two you got to respect them that he's uh
that's it we're all sick and tired of
for years you hear stories and
whatsoever and I don't want to throw
nobody on the bus I'm not here to throw
nobody on bus you hear all these stories
and now as artists comedians whatever
the [__] you want to call yourself
we have the uh
option to put your music up on websites
and
your comedy up on websites that's
[__] big guys that's something we
didn't have [__] 15 years ago 10
years ago we didn't have this option you
know and even then the people who would
do the albums with you would put them on
iTunes and would tell you you make
nothing right they take your [__]
little 40 that you get so you were like
why am I an items now you have the right
to control that they have the numbers
they have graphs they tell you
everything so you listen guys if you're
thinking of [__] doing something do
it already all right you want to whack
off on the TV show do it do it and put
it on iTunes take a chance Columbus did
you don't even know seriously yeah it is
that's it that's all I got to [__]
tell you on a Wednesday night at least I
got an insane deck tonight I'm saying I
gotta talk here by myself I'm
long-winded because you're sitting there
looking at me like I owe you 22 dollars
you know no no no no no no no you can
imitate that you see what I'm saying
I love it man you know what I I just I
love your show and it's like you know I
talked a little bit last time about
being adopted and growing up in the
foster home and it's like you know just
having you know being a self-starter and
not really having that you know and and
hearing a guy like you in your story you
know and it's nice that we're still here
you know we weren't like these trust
fund kids that like hey you know what I
would you know you know I wanted to be a
trusty kid and the cold [__] reality
that was I know that now you look back
at it there's nobody who wakes up and
goes Jesus Christ you know I wish I was
a truck everybody at one time another
goes Jesus Christ they're digging a
trench or they're going into their last
semester and now they've upped the
[__] money on insurance or whatever
the [__] that is tuition and next thing
you see you see these [__] kids they
pull up in the [__] limo and they act
like jerk off and they're doing drugs
and they're [__] [__] hookers and
they're acting like animals and for one
second you wish that was you so you
would act like a decent individual make
your family proud and use their money
for [__] good [__] you know what I'm
saying we never get that I wanted to be
a trust funded kid for years for years I
was like I can't believe I don't wake up
one of them Below open somebody cut my
toenails and [__] like that
something going back to like the high
schools with with the with the BMWs
those kids don't work as hard some some
of them do but some of them get because
of their connections higher up jobs and
maybe they would if they didn't know
anybody
but what you were talking about earlier
about like me doing more work
is
like it's
you know that there's work to be done
but it's no one wants no one wants to do
it no like it's like you you do things
instead of you focus on projects you
might you maybe shouldn't and
you someone tweeted me the other the
other day and said is it isn't it
motivating to work with Joey Diaz and it
is but it's
I learned from you in a way like it's
like I don't want you to be right but
you are a lot of the time and I see how
you you cut away and sometimes I feel
like I'm too young to be cutting away
certain things like maybe I should do
things
to get the experience or something but
the more I I focus on one thing it turns
out better I think
I I'm super high so that made no sense
no no no I get part of your conversation
okay all your conversation is this okay
I don't even know how to describe
how to describe what the [__] he's
saying
but in part it's like what we discussing
the cardia and I
people get a real estate license and
after two years aren't making any money
so they become waiters for 55 hours a
week
and for years they tell people they're
real estate agents but meanwhile they're
raped it their waiters if they take the
55 hours
as being a waiter and cut 55 hours to 25
hours
and for 30 hours a week you really
focus on what it is to be a realtor from
having your car clean
to giving out business cards
to mailing out hello cards
to you know calling people on the phone
and preparing to meet them to do an
insurance appraise or whatever the [__]
it takes this to sign them as a client
if you really do that most people would
get a real estate license work very hard
and they get a cold reality they buy a
course they get sucked into them of
course and the whole thing how the [__]
do I know because I saw
six out of ten of my friends became real
estate [__] agents and not one of
them became Trump that's how I [__]
know okay and there was all one guy was
kind of kinky and he made a little money
he got out he was very smart he learned
how to do loans
with to get loans with a bank account
and he [__] learn how to finagle he
made a couple hundred thousand and he
got out after two years and nobody ever
got the paperwork but besides that I
never know nobody who out of all those
courses became anything because people
take that course and they think they're
going to sit in an office and people are
going to knock on your door and go hey
we want to buy the hundred thousand
dollar house right it don't work that
way especially in today's society you
become a real estate Jack first off
you're going into something that a
million [__] people are into
yeah you know you gotta it's like
becoming a [__] personal trainer
okay you're going into fight against
barracudas you know what you have a
degree in kinesiology you have an
associates and [__] a chemical
[__] Warfare and dietitian and you
work for Bally's for 10 [__] years
and you want 200 an hour
good luck unless you bump into a sucker
like me or some fat [__] or some uh
some actor right or wrong it's 200 well
how long are you gonna think you're
gonna how long are you gonna think
you're gonna hold on to that price
you think if Lee syack comes to you and
goes I want to train but I only pay 75
an hour this guy's gonna go nah I get
200 pass on
you know how long but every of those
guys picks up one guy that keeps them
going for like two years of the shot you
know 750 a month whatever the [__] they
charge Lee it's amazing but
the guys that [__] train [__] like
I've known in this city so far
15 [__] personal trainers none of
them really trained man just like
conversation with them and I watch them
over time yeah out of those 15 13 of
them have moved and this is just the
last three years
but I've kept my eye on their methods
and [__] yeah one of them merged with a
gym and he's you know it's just really
weird how it works out because that's
it's a tough [__] racket out there to
be a personal trainer it's a tough
racket nobody knocks on your [__]
door and says I'm a fat [__] take me I'm
yours exactly I'm Yours there's a lot of
unemployed people out there and applying
online we've talked about before
hundreds of people are playing at those
jobs thousands of people
the chance that they're gonna see your
resume even it's like yeah but what job
are you talking about yeah if you walk
into a real estate agent and you go I
want to be a realtor they'll say do me a
favor
go over there smell the corner tell me
what do you smell
you come back you tell them what you
smell you're hired
wait a second if I run a real estate
agent you know how many agents I don't
give a [__] if you [__] work for me
how high you you come in here you got a
license plate yeah what do you live
1313 Mockingbird Lane okay you got a car
you got a four door yeah my father just
bought me a new BMW I'm ready to go to
work
all right they'll say okay you got a
desk over there look at their lineup
over there you share it with eight
gorillas
sign up for an hour we come in here cold
call
put our signs out get out there
what the [__] do you think you do you
come in there and sit there and the
phone rings we got a house for sale no
you got to get on a [__] phone and
cold call people
again you got to go market yourself you
know what that takes that takes money
and patience because even if this guy
comes in and goes I want to sell your
house waiting if it happens in two
[__] days
so you got to put a year and nine months
in a bothering people and all of a
sudden four houses sorry you got four
[__] listings like now you got four
listings to play with and Austin bam you
saw your first house and all of a sudden
bam you just saw your second house and
all of a sudden guess what you got two
more [__] listings but the one guys
waiting for his grandmother to die
because they gotta run the [__] head
control she got hit by a bicycle and
she's waiting to die she got 32 [__]
million in the house and this goes on
for years Lee you know why because
you're always rotating you're always
shaking hands you're going you're
sticking to what got you to the dance
you know what it took me nine months now
after nine more months guess what Lee
you got 12 listings
and you got three that I got [__]
offers on and all of a suddenly you got
[__] three that sold more and you got
nine more people who referred Julie
you're working with 20 [__] listings
and the office is looking at you going
this guy's a [__] animal
but there's people who don't understand
that because that takes nine months of
real work
and you know what real work is put in 30
hours and there's a realtor like that
doing that [__] and going and waiting
tables on Friday and Saturday but doing
it all day working a double that's
[__] work Jack
yeah
in dealing with that rejection and just
going forward you know I just I was
reading that you know the book that Joe
Rogan always talks about the the war of
art by Stephen pressfield absolutely I
love that book I always pick it up and I
always find something every time I read
it and he was talking about this one
time he goes I was in my 40s it was
humiliating I met this producer and the
whole time he was on his phone and like
he had like the little Bluetooth in or
whatever like a and he goes in he we'd
be talking and then he'd be like hold on
and you just take the phone call and he
goes God I'm just sitting there and he
goes it wasn't like I was you know it
wasn't like I was new to Tinseltown I'd
been around for a while and at one point
the producer says uh hold on this this
is personal I need to take it do you
mind stepping outside I think I grab my
stuff and I go outside I'm in the
waiting room and I'm waiting and 15
minutes goes by 20 an hour goes by and
he's like then the guy comes out and he
goes I'm so embarrassed I'm sorry I
forgot that you were out here uh let's
reschedule this and he goes and I went
down the elevator and I felt like crap
but he goes you know what
I was happy I had that opportunity and
he goes and that's what you got it he
goes and here's the thing it's like the
mat The Matador who's something like he
goes he gets you know he's running from
the bowl he doesn't win that day but
that's okay because at least he's in the
arena he's not in the stands watching
he's not in the parking lot hoping he
could you know I wish I could be there
it's like you know what all right I'll
take my lumps big deal I'll be another
day I'll meet with the producer and I'll
get this movie out can you believe
you're still [__] swinging at 20
years in this time yeah still here 20
years ago we talked about this last
podcast with the last guy who was on and
he was a jiu jitsu guy just having a
commitment to something for 20 years can
you believe it yeah can you [__]
believe it like anything else like an
electrician who says I work for 32 years
that's always been a big accomplishment
to me this guy got up [__] six days a
week and I'm like electrocuted that's
the same thing as being a comedian we
get electrocuted every night like I did
you know what I'm saying I'm only a few
years into my career but it seems like
ever every three to four years you start
looking like major gains like you see
every few months but it seems like it's
like every every three or four years I
don't know if you guys have a different
experience
well I think that people
think that anything that they pick as a
career is easy sometimes especially
something that involves a commission or
something that
where you are expected to
you know generate money
whatever your CEO whatever you know
whatever does I think that uh
what are you laughing about me hit him
down
what do you think Darren
I think he's really high I think you're
[__] high dude I think I've been
breathing on you give me that stuff
let's get him out of here I know he's
got a spot he's got a couple I love it
man
thank you for coming on listen man thank
you add you on you were talking about
that Flappers I overheard you talking to
Lee and I came back and checked the
schedule and I bumped somebody you know
what I want to help Darren out Darren's
a great guy he's done a lot of great
work
I know you put effort into this it's not
like you're a [__] or nothing like that
you know or like I said our desperation
smell is over with yeah and it feels so
nice to walk into a comedy club and to
yeah still remember we 10 million
situations where people calling law amen
do you know that on [__] Tuesday
nights the guy who did Pulp Fiction
hangs out at this place and they do
comedy let's go down and sneak up at
nine o'clock so he would see us like
something's really gonna happen and
people would get [__] creepy about it
you want to give me that stuff sure well
you just don't know you're just trying
everything when you first get here
I'm [__] embarrassing can you be you
know what I'm saying the last time I did
the show I I uh I got a lot of emails
and tweets and I want to say thank you
guys for reaching out I love when people
reach out it shows you you know like I
do morning radio a lot like around the
country yeah yeah yeah even I've done
stuff in L.A and it's like you get like
maybe one maybe one message or two maybe
two and sometimes it's because I'll
tweet it Hey listen to me on blah blah
or and then it's my own people so it's
like you know it's great the power of
podcasts and the connection that we we
have you know as listeners and as uh
performers
I'm you know blown away by this whole
thing every day I learned something new
from an email or by bump into people or
you were you were saying earlier how you
feel when people come up to you how do
you mean how do you think I
my life hasn't really changed yet here
but it doesn't make sense to I don't
really think about what's going on
because it doesn't make sense to me why
would you I'm from bomb from Boston 900
milligrams of THC tonight what was your
voice I do that to you so it doesn't
make sense no but no but it doesn't make
sense that's why I do this with you
think I do this because I like to see
you [__] all over that drooling and
[__] thinking about Mexican food no I do
this so you don't think about what
you're doing what you're doing is Magic
and you don't even know you just over
that [__] like a dunce looking around
like Young Frankenstein well just give
me 900 but because you're tougher than
that but it's crazy like I'm just a dude
from Boston
and it's crazy that people want to take
pictures with me I don't get it so I I
just I don't think I was excited when I
met Lee you know like because I used to
hear you on with Steve Simone and Joey
and I was like that's Lee High Lee it
was I think I might have been Las Vegas
or something but it was like it's cool
you know I I couldn't appreciate it more
but it's just
it's delirious
some of it has gotten creepy at some
points
in your bathroom no if they found my
phone number on like old resumes I had
online
but I luckily took those down but um
you know everyone in the podcast they've
been great ever since
Dr police came on
I've been paying attention to that more
and more I still put the Kettlebell on
my stomach I still do that stuff it
didn't feel anything until today it took
a little longer than 14 [__] days I
ain't gonna lie to you but I stuck with
it you know
one of the things you have to do
basically is sit on the floor and it's
like a condominious type breathing you
know it's like one of those things where
you put your stomach in before you lay
on your back before you put the
Kettlebell and take the deep breaths
and what you're basically doing is
breathing and then there's one thing she
says to close your mouth and you know
relax your jaw and look straight ahead
when you do that and breathe out of your
nose
it's completely different and you kind
of go into a meditative State and lately
I've been thinking about this special
about me on stage what are you gonna
wear what do I want from the special
just to get your mind in order before
Jimmy valeno North Carolina won that
year and the practice is the first three
or four practices made them cut the nuts
down
so they would see what it felt like when
they won the championship to cut the
Nets down that's really [__] good
thinking you know what I'm saying so it
all starts at that [__] I know it sounds
stupid to the people at home you think
I'm smoking dope with eight Indians and
we're spitting out brilliant material it
don't happen that way I don't know
but meditation is real important and
that's uh what headspace has to offer
you as a product okay uh let's be honest
most of your problems start in your mind
fear anger stress anxiety depression
sleeplessness they begin in your head
and they can wreck your life okay I know
for personal experiences man some nights
I go pee and on the way back to lay down
I think about something and it wakes me
the [__] up in the middle of night I
gotta go sit on the couch and smoke 15
bong hits and watch TV to come down from
just thinking about it right
they could wreck your life but it
doesn't have to be that way you can make
major difference in just 10 minutes a
day this change comes through guided
meditation with the new headspace app
headspace is meditation Made Simple it's
guided meditations that you listen to
whenever you want whatever you want
right on your phone computer or tablet
meditation is rooted in thousands of
years of traditions with with scientific
studies that show it's positive effects
like improving Focus relationship
Harmony and decreasing anxiety and
stress for me I use it for the anxiety I
use it for the stress it's just a few
minutes a day and it starts with this
you join over five million users already
getting some headspace for free right
now do me a favor right now you're a
church guy I love you I know maybe
you're having problems try it why not
take a chance Columbus did download the
free headspace app and begin the take 10
program for 10 days of guided meditation
at space.com Joey the headspace take 10
program is a hundred percent free way to
experience the benefits of meditation in
your busy Modern Life we do when you
think when you finish at the gym you're
trying to lose weight you're at the gym
you got your heart rate up the [__]
2000 you're thinking about cookies and
[__] pepperoni pizza how do you think
you come down from that anxiety you go
in the corner you stretch your
hamstrings
you know you stretch your back a little
bit you do a couple of those [__]
yoga things you know you do those other
things the cat core poses and after it's
all over you're sitting out for [__]
two minutes
you take your T-shirt off you don't give
a [__] about your stomach as if you're a
man you take your shirt off you get a
little Freedom you cross your legs you
relax your [__] hands he just breathe
and breathe at what you want to do what
just happened
and what you expect and all of a sudden
you just say a [__] little prayer you
clean that bad [__] air out which I
haven't done for years see that's what I
was doing the doctor please didn't open
my eyes still you have to spit that
[__] hair out you can breathe all you
want but if you don't spit that hold
that air and push your stomach out yeah
when I take those [__] tablets she
sent me those you lick this thing and it
gives you a THC your pH whatever balance
in your [__] you got to get it
between six and seven it was days that I
was at like [__] Darkness because I
got the sleep apnea machine and I'm not
breathing fully that's why when I wake
up if I make a quick move I almost have
a [__] heart attack I figured all
this [__] out all with that [__] book
so I'm happy she came on I'm happy she
turned me on to meditation that's my
[__] point all right like Lee said in
the beginning of the uh podcast we we're
getting sponsored by somebody who
impressed the [__] out of me it's not
too Sarah you know why they had the hemp
products and that's all great but one
thing I didn't mention how the products
are exceptional
that little Jiu Jitsu bag they sent me
they sent me a canteen okay I filled
that up with water I get the other thing
I filled that up with water I put
protein after the drink I fill that in
that [__] bag then on the other side
I put my two towelettes and my nasal
spray okay and then on the other pocket
I put my [__] phone and my wallet
okay and then in the [__] bag I put a
pair of shorts a T-shirt and a towel
okay and then I gotta bring this
infected because my knee pads are rotten
they smell like 10 dead dicks so I gotta
wipe my [__] knees before I get
scurvy or whatever [__] grows on the
back of your [__] legs right don't
worry I own a new knee pads from Amazon
I know the [__] sucker page anyway and
then anyway what the [__] I'm saying is
the bag is tremendous it feels great
it's tough It's got a strap it's got two
different handles I got pockets for
[__] the fungi soap I got a new thing
with the soap now I got this new fungi
soap I just stick my toe in it and let
it cement on my toes like in the old
days how they throw you in the Hudson
River
with cement boots I just have a cement
toe how long do you stick in there for
for like eight nine minutes until I get
bored I gotta go somewhere what the [__]
is with the questions I don't [__]
anyway I'm sorry well my [__] point
is I got the fanny pack I flew with last
week I had my nasal spray and I had my
pens I had two Peg glasses one of them
broke but that was my fault they're
[__] three for ten dollars what do
you think are they gonna last forever I
got my [__] uh you know whatever the
[__] you need it's around your waist a
lot of people are sitting there looking
at me like Joey what are you [__] gay
you're following you but no let me tell
you something I'm no fat man I don't
like [__] in my wallets okay so you put
all that [__] shitness in the thing
there and you that's it you fly like
that they got the the what do they call
those things the the fanny packs they
got the bag for jiu jitsu okay they sent
me a beautiful [__] sweatshirt I wear
it outside Jiu Jitsu attempt it's strong
it's solid it's [__] light any way
you put it listen do me a favor go to DS
gear right now they got the rash guards
they got geese they got a ghee hemp uh
tremendous this
please go to dsgear.com right now
you like something tell them I sent you
get five percent off what do they put in
the Box Joey Joey j-o-e-y bam in the Box
you get five percent off go look at this
stuff it's hemp you [__] love
smoking weed and you want to support the
cause and you love Woodstock well hey
start by going the dsgear.com right now
I'm giving you a nickel percent off
today all right and don't forget it
thebestonic.com saving me here 53 my
liver looks like a [__] skank you
know I don't even know what my [__]
liver looks like my liver looks like one
of those rivers in Newark there's no
even alligators there's just dead
[__] bones
shroom attack the sweating the whole
[__] thing has saved my [__] life
okay with the Alpha Brain the focus the
hemp protein powder I'm losing a
centimeter of fat every two weeks you
understand me at least I'm going forward
why because I'm paying attention and on
it sent me all those products I tried
them now they support me and [__] it
with Partners now and I love them and I
think you should [__] try them so do
me a favor I can sit here and be an
encyclopedia [__] I ain't even gonna
bother you with that go to honda.com
right now and press in church get 10 off
before you [__] press ten percent off
look at the line of products they got I
can't help you with the weights and the
sticks but the supplements I'm your
[__] Goomba okay I'm giving you 10
off right now to get shipped to your
house on it.com
headspace.com Joey and that's usara the
best
dsgear.com who's better than you
[__] Darren Carter I wish you
nothing but luck listen again do me a
favor I don't bring some [__] uh
Johnny come lately on the [__] show
to in fact I want you to play Lay Down
Sally on the way a little Eric Clapton
we're going slow hands out of respect
for d c the British Supreme anyway this
guy's I've known him for a while
22 000 people have come and gone me and
DC is still here he fights for his
[__] life he plays Chattanooga
wherever they need him DC's there black
people white people albinos
corporates these kids are [__] real
Superstar any day now somebody will put
them as a partner in some talk show at
midnight he makes a half a Mill and
everybody's happy for him because he put
the time in and that's the most
important thing but it all starts with
your supports on the iTunes charts
because people look at that [__] it's
like the minor leagues they do
I love you Joey I love you Lee thank you
I love you where are you at next brother
Mr CD Premiere party we're gonna we're
gonna figure that out I don't know right
now
thank you let's do that I'm at Helium
next week and it's sold out and after
that I'm having no surgery I'm going to
Vegas to Joe July 8th I'm having no
surgery after that and you won't see my
cuban ass till [__] Oklahoma [__]
I love you [__] yeah we'll be
back this [__] we listen Monday
morning you're gonna wake up
you're gonna have a new [__] podcast
that's how I roll [__] bam I love you
[__] stay black Uncle Joey
the Church of What's Happening Now [__]
now [__] I love it
is this the Kidz Bop version I have no
idea
is this the kids my friends ain't worse
than this [__] guy
nothing that is wrong
with me
let's go
[Music]
foreign
thank you
again
foreign